la transformation du visage de nos cités
semblent être le caractère dominant de
la seconde moitié du siècle le quartier
latin lui même a changé de personnalité
et l'étudiant des années 30 en
pèlerinage aux sources aurait peine à
reconnaître le boul mich de ses 20 ans
l'époux solides bastions ne pas résister
aux assauts d'une évolution un placard
même les établissements dont la présence
en ces lieux paraît logique sont
directement menacés par la double
offensive de la chaussure et de
l'habillement le boul mich est en pleine
évolution le quartier latin émérite de
moins en moins son nom
certes la sorbonne est toujours là mais
la terminologie ne sauve que les
apparences les pôles d'attraction
estudiantin odyssée vers l'ouest les
carrefours mabillon et de l'odéon ont
pris la relève de la halle aux vins à la
chambre des députés le boulevard saint
germain est devenu l' axe principal du
paris université saint germain des prés
aussi a changé il ya 15 ans jean paul
sartre y régnait avec simone de beauvoir
le quartier vie s'amuse gréco mais
depuis cette époque juliette gréco a
changé de profil et le café de flore de
clients père
il ya 15 ans pas d'effet était leur père
d'une espèce indéfinissable les
existentialistes une faune qui vivaient
dans les cars affectionner l'hermétisme
intellectuelle et affichait un souverain
mépris pour les apparence extérieure la
mode devait durer plusieurs années
aujourd'hui à saint germain des prés la
clientèle ne fait que passer
elle vient le plus souvent d'auteuil et
de la muette le complète issue anglais
et la robe de soie ont tendance à
remplacer le blood j
le décor aussi a fait des concessions
les nouveaux établissements ne se
veulent plus intellectuel mais
fonctionnel
soyons justes la décoration conçu par
slavik dans le style 1900 donne à
l'ensemble une personnalité
incontestable du 1er janvier à la saint
sylvestre et jusqu'à 2 heures du matin
on y trouve à peu près tout ce qu'on
veut
rares témoins d'une époque révolue
l'épicerie depuis 15 ans elle n'a guère
changé la frite et les conserves ils
sont la providence d'une clientèle
fidèle à travers les générations
seule nouveauté les attractions
spontanée
à
ambiance joyeuse aussi aux assassins
les danses également évolué il ya 15 ans
c'était la folie du rhin
aujourd'hui dans les caves de
saint-germain-des-prés l'ambiance est
celle de la plus correcte des surboum
les danses sont devenues plus
sophistiquées
signe des temps il y à moi de bohème à
saint germain des prés il n'y a presque
plus que des étudiants des presque vrai